[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle rabia et à
l'âge de 17 ans j'ai eu la chance de
finir ma scolarité dans un lycée au pays
de galles pendant deux ans j'ai côtoyé
des jeunes venant de tous horizons et
venant de plus de 90 pays différents
auprès d'eux j'ai appris de très grandes
de son grâce notamment à la diversité de
leur expérience de leur mode de vie et
également de leur culture je suis ici
pour vous montrer et pour vous prouver
que si cette diversité est recherchée
nourris et même célébré à l'échelle
individuelle pam à l'échelle collective
elle peut être la plus grande source de
savoir et de richesses j'ai une
définition de la diversité qui est assez
étendu car pour moi elle va au delà de
la multiculturalité ou de la
multiethnicité pour moi il existe
également une diversité socio économique
car nous n'avons pas tous et toutes les
mêmes richesses matérielles ni les mêmes
statuts sociaux
il existe également une diversité
intergénérationnelle car nous n'avons
pas tous mais et tout vécu la même
histoire du fait de notre âge
il ya aussi la diversité dans le
handicap la validité d'invalidité et
finalement la diversité neurologiques
qu'on oublie souvent qui concerne par
exemple les personnes atteintes
d'autisme pour recontextualiser j'ai été
sélectionné par l'organisation non
gouvernementale w c pour finir mon lycée
au prix de jeunes de tous horizons
le but du mouvement et de cette
organisation est de faire de l'éducation
une force pour unir les peuples les
nations et les cultures pour la paix et
le développement durable à l'origine le
mouvement a été créé dans le contexte
incertain de la guerre froide et les
fondateurs de l'époque avait donc
accueilli et réunit des étudiants venant
des deux blocs et avait réalisé qu'en
fait en se côtoyant les élèves pouvaient
aller outre leur prix jugé être à nous
mêmes parfois collaborer sur des
problématiques concernant leurs peuples
respectifs 57 ans plus tard j'ai été
diplômé moi même de cette institution
et même si le contexte actuel
extrêmement différent de celui de la
guerre froide les valeurs inculquées
dans cet établissement sont toujours
centrale est nécessaire au monde
d'aujourd'hui
c'est pour cela que j'ai envie de
partager aujourd'hui avec vous quelques
anecdotes et quelques expériences sur
cette diversité
prenez mon expérience et cette
intervention comme une invitation à
aller
alors rencontres de la diversité pour
vous enrichir sans forcément passer par
le même parcours que le mien la première
anecdote que je vais vous raconter c'est
une anecdote qui est assez humiliante
mais qui a été l'une des plus grande
leçon d'humilité de ma vie à ce jour et
cette anecdote elle se passe le premier
jour de mon arrivée sur le campus où je
savais que je devais partager ma chambre
avec trois films du coup de trois
continents différents et je m'attendais
bien sûr ah bah c'est une super demi de
sommeil
sauf que bien sûr ça c'est pas du tout
passé comme ça en fait pendant la nuit
il y avait une sonnerie qui a retenti et
qui venait du lit d'une de mes colocs en
particulier donc clairement je n'étais
pas contente
mais j'ai décidé quand même le lendemain
de gentiment confronter ma coloc par
rapport à la salle et c est là qu au
bout d'une courte réflexion
elle me répond ah oui c'est vrai c'est
ma pompe à insuline qui sonne pendant la
nuit avec le temps je ne l'entend plus
donc là quand j'entends insuline je
comprends que ma collègue est atteinte
de diabète ce que je ne savais
absolument pas mais je n'avais aucune
idée de l'utilité de cette fameuse pompe
à insuline et j'ai commis une petite
erreur en lui demandant s'il pouvait les
tendres pendant la nuit parce que
c'était vraiment très désagréable pour
moi c'est là qu'elle me regarde droit
dans les yeux et qu'elle me dit si je
les temps je risque de mourir donc s'est
installée entre nous à un moment de gêne
extrême mais c'était le début d'une très
grande amitié
cette expérience m'a fait me rendre
compte que mon confort ne vaudra jamais
la vie de quelqu'un et que ce confort et
parfois construit autour de l'ignorance
de la vie des autres par exemple un
petit confort qu'on se permet tous de
faire c'est de faire du shopping
saisonniers dans des enseignes qui
proposent des prix alléchants mais
qu'ils ont c'est derrière contribuer l
esclavage des wings cours en chine
est ce que aujourd'hui concrètement ce
petit confort qu'on se permet tous de
faire vos la vie la sécurité et la
liberté de gens à des kilomètres de chez
nous mais qui sont quand même des gens
je suis convaincu que non et je suis
convaincu qu'avec un petit changement de
mode de vie comme consommer une mode
plus éthique ou boycottez peuvent
réellement changé la vie de quelqu'un
bien sûr un boycott seul ne sera pas
suffisante pour sortir le oui gourde
leur situation déplorable
mais cela prouve juste que en tant
qu'individu on possède un impact immense
surtout en ce qui concerne ce qu'on
consomme en parlant d'un pacte qu'on a
sur la vie de gens à des kilomètres de
chez nous j'ai une autre histoire à vous
raconter
c'est l'histoire d'une conversation
bouleversante que j'ai eu avec une amie
des maldives donc à l'époque moi je ne
connaissais absolument rien des maldives
à part le fait que c'était un archipel
d'îles paradisiaques dans le pacifique
mais à part ça je n'y connaissais rien
je me doutais qu'il devait y avoir un
certain impact écologique
donc j'avais demandé à mon ami son
ressenti par rapport à la montée des
eaux et par rapport à comment le
changement climatique affectés
concrètement son quotidien elle me
raconte déjà qu environ 40 cl de
l'archipel sont déjà submergés et que
elle et ses concitoyens étaient préparés
à ce qu'un jour ils n'auraient plus de
maison et plus de pays il était
conscient et préparer qu'un jour il
allait devenir réfugiés climatiques
d'après l'onu d'ici 2050 le nombre de
réfugiés climatiques pourrait atteindre
le milliard donc mon ami va probablement
faire partie ce qui m'a le plus marqué
dans cette conversation s'était
réellement son honnêteté un peu en
différentes s'ils n'étaient pas qu'elle
avait abandonné tout espoir
mais c'était que réellement elle se
sentait impuissante dans cette situation
on le sait maintenant ce sont les plus
grosses entreprises multinationales qui
polluent le plus et qui causent le plus
de dégâts dans des petits pays comme les
maldives
ici encore la meilleure en tant qu homme
faisait dans un impact énorme sur des
lieux lointains qui sont refuge de
biodiversité exceptionnelle de culture
absolument merveilleuse et de réussir un
incroyable sens cette conversation avec
mon ami des maldives n'aurait jamais
réalisé l'ampleur du problème écologique
et comment concrètement cela affecte la
vie quotidienne des citoyens et même
leur avenir
la dernière anecdote que je vais vous
raconter c'est l'histoire un engagement
que j'ai tenus pendant deux ans auprès
de maisons de retraite au pays de galles
et en musicienne j'ai eu l'immense
opportunité de partager ma passion et
mes compétences pour mener à bien
session de musicothérapie pour des
personnes âgées souvent atteintes
d'alzheimer
ces personnes là sont souvent isolés
premièrement de par leur maladie mais
également de par leur incapacité à
communiquer verbalement
grâce à cette musicothérapie j'ai réussi
à nouer des liens très forts avec ses
patients et j'ai beaucoup appris sur les
communications verbales sur les besoins
des personnes vulnérables et également
sur les chansons folk et galways et
anglaise je me souviens d'une dame qui
est au début de mon service ne parlait
pas ne chantait pas et avait un regard
perdu au bout de deux ans de
musicothérapie
elle souriait elle chantait et pouvait
tenir une conversation absolument normal
bien sûr la musicothérapie n'est pas une
cure miracle mais dans ce cas si elle a
réussi à sortir quelqu'un de son
isolement
finalement c'est grâce à l'interaction
avec des gens avec extrêmement différent
du mien que j'ai pu me forget mes
propres aux opinions sur une diversité
de sujets en étant exposés directement à
des gens qui étaient affectés par cette
ces problématiques et surtout je tiens à
insister là dessus
aucun bouquin ne m'a appris à compatir
avec quelqu'un qui a fui la guerre est
vécue en exode avant sa majorité
aucun livre ne m'a appris à compatir
avec quelqu'un qui a perdu sa maison et
son frère pendant un bombardement
aucun livre m'a appris à communiquer
avec ma coloc dominicaine qui ne savait
pas parler un mot d'anglais quand je les
rencontre et et aucun bouquin ne m'a
appris à communiquer et à être amis
manière sensible avec quelqu'un qui
attend nautisme pourtant c'est quelque
chose que j'ai dû apprendre sur le tas
tout ça pour dire que j'ai appris tout
cela au contact de la diversité ce sont
des gens à l'opposé de mon identité de
mon mode de vie et de mes convictions
qui m'ont appris ces choses là c'est
l'interaction humaine qui m'a permis de
déconstruire les préjugés que moi même
je ne pensais pas avoir
je conçois que mon expérience avec la
diversité est assez privilégiés mais je
suis convaincu que chacun d'entre nous
peut aller à la recherche de cette
diversité et construire ses propres
interaction avec la diversité un très
bon moyen d'interagir avec la diversité
sans forcément
sors de chez soi c'est d'utiliser
internet sur internet on peut trouver
des témoignages absolument poignant de
gens venant de près de chez nous mais
très loin de chez nous et je pense qu'on
devrait exploiter mieux cet outil dans
nos sociétés actuelles
il ya également une diversité qu'il
faudrait qu'on exploite plus pour
qu'elles puissent bénéficier à la
société car diversité implique aussi des
compétences diversifiées
on a souvent tendance à l'effacer cette
diversité sous prétexte d'être
égalitaire mais cela devient
contre-productif car on ne prend pas le
temps de la comprendre d'accepter
totalement son existence et puis si on
le souhaite
la célébrer une autre manière de vous
créer des opportunités d'interaction
avec la diversité c'est de vous engager
trouvez-vous en service civique qui vous
intéressent engagez-vous auprès de cette
ong qui se bat pour les mêmes causes que
vous et surtout parler à des gens au
parcours différent du vôtre découvrir
l'histoire est partagé à votre ce
message s'adresse à toutes générations
confondues
mais j'ai une pensée particulière pour
ma génération qui a vu ses espoirs se
réduire à néant à cause d'une crise que
personne n'a su gérer ni prédire
correctement cette génération qui a
également hérité des lourds fardeaux qui
sont de restituer un trop plein et sa
grandeur mais également de poursuivre la
lutte contre les inégalités de genre
socio-économique et raciale pour
surmonter tout cela il faut prendre en
considération les besoins de tous et
pour cela il faut les connaître il faut
apprendre des autres et s'améliorer pour
améliorer le monde